Picked at my face, and it's got a scab.
And I don't know if that's good or bad to tell you because,
you can stop leaving a comment about it, I know it's there,
but now if you didn't know, maybe it's all you're seeing...
Making video content is fun for your insecurities!
*bouncy noise*
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know now you know!
Welcome to the Internet's most...mildly tolerated game?
This isn't a game.
Last week I made a video showing you how you can make
five YouTuber Halloween costumes using five items for each costume,
And I'm going to repeat that five on five.
Please tolerate me.
See how quickly you can guess which Youtuber I'm making a costume for,
and then see if you win!
We're all winners here!
Oh no, no, no, no... No.
Let's just jump right into it.
Costume number one:
For this first costume, you're gonna need some comfortable leggings,
some Ugg boots, a comfy shirt or sweatshirt,
blonde hair,
as much technology, iPhones, cameras... that you can find,
and a sister that you constantly try to force on camera with you.
Jenna!
No Justine, I'm busy!
And there you have it! You are:
*weird nasal 'wooww!' sound*
Costume number two:
For this costume you're gonna need an outfit that's goddamn adorable,
brown perfect hair that's goddamn adorable,
a bow that's goddamn adorable,
some cookware that's goddamn adorable,
and the inability to offend anyone even when you say the word 'f*ck*.
F*ck.
Tada! You're:
*low-throated 'oooh' sound*
Costume number three:
For this costume you're gonna need a glamorous outfit that clearly breathes well,
some high heels that clearly make your feet feel awesome,
some blond hair,
pink pouty lips all damn day,
and a master's degree in the art of Instagram posing.
Tada! You are:
*weird high pitched, nasal 'yeeeahhh!'*
Costume number four:
For this costume, you need a cool comfortable, yet approachable outfit,
a signature red lip,
the longest amount of dark brown hair I've ever seen in my life,
This is the best I could do
A t-shirt reference 'Can I get you any drugs?'
Whaddap t-shirt reference!
And the signature hand gesture that I can never figure out exactly how to do.
And tada! You're:
*kids 'ahhh' sound*
And costume number five:
For this costume you need some sort of older t-shirt with maybe an animal face on it,
some brown boy hair,
a five o'clock shadow, all the clocks of the day,
a dog that's totally over you 'Uno!'
and an open love-hate relationship with food.
I love you! I hate you!
Ohh, I love you again!
Look at that you're:
*gravelly male, 'whoa!'*
Okay, that's it for another Youtuber Halloween...costume...idea.
My eye, sorry.
I shouldn't apologise for being a goddamn human.
I'm very sorry.
Leave a comment down below, letting me know what other Youtubers I should make Halloween costumes for.
Subscribe to this YouTube channel, I make videos Monday, Wednesday and Friday.
And also, make sure you click that bell notification, so you get notified
when I make THIS sweet-ass content!
Other than that, I don't know.
If you haven't already gotten an 'I Don't Know' sweatshirt, the link is in the description box below.
There's only like six days left?
So go get 'em while they're-
No temperature, just on the Internet.